مرحبا بلما تم طرح برومو مسلسل بابا
المجال للفنان مصطفى شعبان وقبل رمضان
وهناك حاله فضول وجدل كبيرين والان وبعد
ايام من عرض العمل يبدو ان الجمهور اهدا
ربما اعجابهم القصه التي تدور في منطقه
شعبيه يمر فيها البطل بمواقف وازمات حيث
يعمل في مجال التجاره ويواجه خصم شديد جدا
وهو باسم سمره مسلسل شيق لانه قصه شعبيه
بتلمس كل واحد ماشي في الشارع
تلمس كل واحد في سواء في منطقه شعبيه او
مش في منطقه شعبيه في مصر او كمان في
العالم العربي الموضوع اللي فيه
المسلسل بيهم اغلبيه الناس
مش هلاقي حاجه اقولها اكتر ان انا معايا
كم نجوم مرعب يعني بتشرف بيهم واضافه
كبيره جدا ليا في مسيرتي يعني وضفا للعمل
كمان شخصيه مراسي هي شخصيه يعني شعبيه
وكده طبعا مسلسل هو كله صراع ما بين الخير
والشر
احداث كثيره مراسي احداث العمل يضم كوكب
النجوم يثني الجمهور والنقاد عليهم دائما
يقال انهم خطفوا الاضواء في هذا العمل وهم
الفنانه سوسن بدر والفنان رياض الخولي
والد ووالده مصطفى شعبان في العمل ليستهدف
الجيل الجديد والشباب وقيمه العائله
والعلاقات ما بينهم كبير زي مصطفى شعبان
احب جدا اني اكون معاه في رمضان في علاقه
خاصه جدا بتربطها بابنها
[موسيقى]
بتتطرح الظروف ان هي اللي تتولى تربيته
ومن ساعه ما بيبقى الطفل رضيع يعني
وبنشوف بقى الرحله بينهم هم الاتنين
الرحله الطويله دي بتبقى فيها ايه حلو
وايه مش حلو وايه يمروا صعب خصوصا ان هي
هتمر بالظروف صحيه
بتضطروا بقى هو اللي يشيل مسئوليه في
الفتره دي دي يعني كلام كده سريع عن
الموضوع شخصيه جميله
خطيبه زين
يعني متربيين مربيها من وهي صغيره
وكبروا مع بعض ولسه هنشوف الاحداث ان شاء
الله وهي مجموعه رائعه من النجوم اللي
مبسوطه قوي قوي بالعمل معهم نستعرض الان
بعض الاراء حول العالم
[موسيقى]